welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
eliminate temperature sensitivity and
lyophilization technology it's my
pleasure to introduce you to amy webster
a custom manufacturing service leader
with genomics and diagnostic solutions
at sativa for complete biography of our
speaker please visit the tab at the top
of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box our speaker will
address your questions following the end
of our presentation
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter amy webster i will now turn
the presentation over to her welcome amy
so thank you very much for the kind
introduction
we're here today to talk about how to
eliminate temperature sensitivity with
lyophilizing localization technology
so first off we're going to give you a
brief introduction as to who i am and
who saitiva is and then we go through
the principles of loyolization how you
would do it what you can use it for and
why you would do it
and i can then go through a case study
for you
and give you some further information
and links to videos of the site
and then go through any questions
so introduction
um my name's amy and i work at the
cardiff manufacturing site for saitva
in the uk
i am part of a team called the
customized solutions team and we're a
team of seven dedicated scientists and
we have
we are entirely dedicated to
customer projects and we have no r d
responsibilities
we have five main services
what we call
plates conjugation contract
manufacturing custom biology and
localization
so the
contract manufacturing we can take your
process and we can manufacture in-house
plates we've got a range of filter
plates that we can put custom membranes
in
contract uh custom biology we can take
any of our catalog products and
customize it to your requirements
conjugation we have a range of magnetic
beads that we can conjugate antibodies
or oligos to
and lyo stable is our freeze drying and
localization service which we're going
to go through in more detail
so
localization how do you do it what can
you do it to and why would you do it
so lyophilization is a stabilizing
technique which takes a liquid freezes
it sublimes all the moist or the water
from it and leaves you with a solid
classy cake
the
with the cake being a solid the reagents
in it can no longer move and there is
there should be no side reactions and no
degradation occurring in the solid state
benefits of lyophilization so why would
you want to layoffalice
one of the big advantages of
lyophilization is ambient storage and
shipment
this means that you no longer have to
ship enzymes and other reagents around
the world on dry ice and ambient
conditions everything can go in the same
package it can be stored at point of use
at ambience you don't need a minus 80
and -20 and a fridge at the same time
and this saves
not only in dry ice and
benefiting the environment but also
as the shipper it saves an awful lot of
money being able to ship at ambient
rather than needing dry ice
it also significantly simplifies the
workflow at point of use
all of the formulation has been done in
one big batch beforehand and has been qc
tested so
each one of the lyophilized pellets or
cakes has the same activity and has
already been tested the end user only
has to add the sample and then run the
experiment
this means that the end user can run
multiple different tests using exactly
the same protocol by just changing the
loyalized cake
with a big batch size you only have to
run one qc for the entire batch and your
repeatability and reliability of your
save will be improved
and
the
the simplification of the workflow at
the point of use also means that
your
the
waste is reduced
of not only the raw materials but also
of plastic wear and tips there is less
for petting steps there is less threes
flooring of the enzymes
the mix you use on day one will be the
same as the mix you use on day five
so what type of assays can we lyophilize
most types and if we've not done it
we'll definitely give it a go
so we've done
lamp assays qpcr rt pcr
with that we've done many enzymes we've
done rna for qc analysis
and
ngs sequencing
we've got a range of catalog beads which
do genomic fly and template which are
rolling circle amplifications
we've lyophilized conjugated mag beads
and we've also
started lyophilizing a range of exosomes
and biological reagents along those
lines
so how do you design your assay for
lowercalization three main points and
we're going to go through each of them
the first one is excipients second one
is formulation
the third one is what format you want to
put it in cakes or beats
so first off the excipients
now excipients are very important for
lyophilization for two main reasons
one they provide the structure for the
cake
which aids in the reconstitution and
also the stability but more importantly
is they protect any
delicate
materials that are in the cake
enzymes and proteins have a complicated
folding structure and in a solution this
folding structure is held in place by
the hydrogen bonds from the water
molecules
during lyophilization you'll be removing
the water molecules so you need to
replace
those into intramolecular bonding with
something else otherwise the protein is
going to denature
and it's the excipients that take over
this
is
it's the excipients that take over this
bonding and would retain the activity of
the enzymes
sativa has developed
a range of different
proprietary exhibits that are compatible
with many different applications and
have proven to be
to give stable product
one thing with the excipients is they
can
create
the
excipients can interfere with your
downstream assay
so the less excipients that we have to
put into the lyophilized cake the better
the main way we do this is
if you had a say 50 microliter pcr
we would dispense the reagents and
excipients in 10 microliters we would
lyophilize a 10 microliter cake or a
bead and then at point of use it would
be reconstituted in 50 microliters which
would significantly decrease the amount
of excipient in the downstream
applications
the next important thing is the
formulation
you're about to spend hours removing all
the water from the solution so
as if you can concentrate
some if you can concentrate the raw
materials and reduce the amount of water
you add you have a lot less water to
remove
things like changing primer
concentrations from 10 micromolar to one
millimolar magnesium concentrations to
one molar and things like that
there is a limit to the amount you can
concentrate your reagents and normally
this is defined this
normally is limited by the salt
concentration
now
as you know you
they spread salt on the rose to prevent
it freezing so increasing the salt
concentration in your assay will
decrease the freezing temperature
the long the more you decrease the
freezing temperature the harder it's
going to be to lyophilize
there are a few other things that
lyophilization can't cope with the main
one being glycerol
so
for lyophilization we often have to
source either no glycerol or very high
concentration enzymes so that we really
limit the amount of glycerol going into
the solution
another solvent that we don't like is
dmso
and again too much dmso will prevent the
localization from being successful
as
the plastic wear that is used to
lyophilize is also
very important when you think about the
cycle
the design
whether or not the plastic wear is going
in the freeze dryer and the shape of the
plastic wear
will significantly impact the ability to
lyophilize
we also need to be able to properly seal
the plastic wet so that after we've
dried the cake we can maintain that in a
proper environment and we'll go into
slightly more detail about that later on
the next thing that we need to decide is
what format we want to end
now at sativa we have two formats which
we call cakes and beads
both of them use the same proprietary
excipient mix and probe both of them use
the same processes
the difference being
the order at which they are localized
and put into plastic ware
so for cakes we'll do the formulation we
will then dispense into the final
plastic wear and then we will lyopulize
in situ in that plastic ware
with this method we put in the plastic
ware into the freezer so the plastic
needs to be able to
cope with the freeze drying
cycle and because of this our batch size
is limited to about twenty thousand
reactions
for the bead format what we do is we do
the formulation we then drop and they
form spherical beads and we lay off the
lies in those spheres
we then pick and place those beads into
the final plastic ware
and seal those and pack those
our typical batch size for beads is
anywhere from 5 000 to 350 000 reactions
so both formats
and can use pretty much any plastic wear
tubes and files that you'd like that can
be sealed
so going through stages of a freeze
drying cycle
so the first thing we need to do
after we put the
after we've done the formulation and
dispensed it is to freeze the mix
the this is important because the next
thing the next step we're going to do is
put a vacuum and if the mix is not
properly frozen then the vacuum will
pull the liquid out of the tube and we
will lose the entire cake
one thing we can do in the freezing step
is to use annealing steps which cycle
between solid and liquid
this will form bigger ice crystals which
would make drying easier
the next stage is primary dry in this
the vacuum is poured so it will pull
these
the conditions in the chamber below the
triple point
this causes ice to sublime from a solid
into a gas and dries the
that dries the cake
during this stage all of the unbound
moisture all of the unbound water is
removed from the cake
the
length of the primary dry is very
dependent on the
height of the cake
so the
the cake dries from the top down water
is removed from the top layer and then
as you can see in the second and third
pictures
the the cake
proceeds downwards the tube
so tall thin cakes will take a lot
longer to dry
the temperature of which the primary dry
is set at will depend on the salt
concentration and the formulation
in general higher salt concentrations
need lower temperatures to dry
the lower the primary dry and the
greater the vacuum that's pulled the
longer it will take to dry
after all of the bound water has been
sorry after all of the unbound water has
been removed in the primary dry we then
move on to the secondary dry
a lot of freeze dryers can have
endpoint determination tests at the end
of the primary dry which will determine
when this is
so they can be used to automatically
extend extend cycles when needed in the
secondary dry the temperature in the
chamber is raised and the bound water is
then removed
again at the end of this stage a lot of
freeze dryers can do
endpoint determinations and confirm that
no more water is coming off
after the cycle is finished the freeze
dryer then goes into a storage phase
this
effectively stops anything else from
happening and allows the
cycles to be repeatable day after day
in the storage phase the machine's
basically just holding everything in
status until it is ready to be unloaded
so you've just spent a day or two
removing all of the moisture from your
cake we then need to pack it in a way
that it's going to maintain its dryness
and any extra water
any water that the cake absorbs is going
to
reduce its stability so the stability of
the cake comes from it being a solid
none of the reagents can move and start
interacting with each other but any
water ingress into the cake is going to
increase the mobility of the reagents in
there allowing degradation or side
reactions to start happening
so the primary seal that we put onto the
cake it can either be done in the freeze
dryer by means of collapsing shelves and
driving bungs into vials
or we can move them into either a
nitrogen box or a dry box which are held
at very low humidities so under one
percent humidity and then we put a foil
seal on
the cakes that then sealed we then
pouch into a desiccated foil pouch with
whatever label is the customer requires
on there and this step is done in a room
that's held under 35 humidity
so if stored in the sealed foil pouch
then our typical stability is for well
over a year for custom products
so going on to a case study
so earlier on this year we there was a
company called gene drive who are a
point of care diagnostic company
they came to us and asked us to help to
work with them to develop a covert test
that could be used in labs around the
world
so
just going to talk through
in three months we managed to
design develop and then transfer a covet
assay
so for the first stage we sat down and
planned out the project with gene drive
with their requirements that the
tests would be able to be used in labs
worldwide this meant that it would have
to be able to be used in multiple
different thermal cyclers now a lot of
different thermocyclers have
need different tube types
and to prevent having to transfer from
after they've reconstituted the
cake or the bead we don't we did not
want to have to transfer that
reconstituted reagent into another tube
to be able to run
so this meant that we would have to
uh
this meant that we would have to have
many different plastic wares for this
product
as it was a covered test the forecast
was also very big and the demand would
have been high because of this we
decided on the bead format
now we the first steps we did were some
initial proof of principle runs in the
dedicated r d facility
so at cardiff we have two facilities
one set up one's dedicated to r d and
one's dedicated to manufacture
both of which have the same
pretty much the same equipment but the r
d version slightly smaller
so with gene drive
gene drive designed the
test and centers down the reagents
we lyophilized several different
versions of it sometimes in the same run
sometimes in different runs took them
out the freeze dryer and sent them back
up to gene drive as quickly as possible
we then sit down and go through the
results with gene drive decide on the
next steps
so after several iterations we came upon
a formulation that we was fixed
we were happy with and we then looked to
transfer this into manufacture
so during the transfer process what we
wanted to do was ensure that we had a
robust product and that it would
we'd be able to manufacture it day in
day out
so we worked with gene drive and decided
that we would run three different
batches and we'd slowly scale up
from an r d size run to a manufacture
size run
now the
the idea of the product with gene drive
is that we would manufacture one batch
of bulk beads
and these bulk beads could be stored at
sativa and then dispensed into the
plastic where needed so there are four
different types of plastic wear
depending on which thermocyclers would
need to be used
and we'd be able to use the one bulk
one batch of bulk bees to dispense into
any of these plate types
after we'd run the transfer runs we sat
down again with gene drive and confirmed
that
we were happy with the results they were
happy with the results
and that with the transfer have been
successful and this product was now
launched in manufacture
so currently it's in manufacture the
manufacturing team run this
regularly
and because of the the way the assay has
been designed when gene drive have
discovered that a further form plate
type is needed
then the
then it's a simple case of validating
the new ceiling methods for the plates
but the bog beats remain the same so we
can launch new products quickly
so to summarize gene drive came to us at
the beginning of the year wanting to
develop a cover test
we worked with them to streamline the
tests push it through our systems as
quickly as possible while covering
everything that we needed to cover
and we now have a
reliable
and we now have a manufacturing product
which is suitable for covet tests around
the world in many different
thermocyclers
so we've got a couple of places where we
can get more information
there is a video which
shows you our live stable facility and
takes you on a tour around our lab
we've got a couple of papers that are
useful and we've also got a form to
we also have a form for you to request a
proof of principle run
thank you very much and is there any
questions
thank you amy for the outstanding
presentation we will now move to the
live q a portion of the presentation as
a reminder to the audience please submit
your questions via the q a box
so let's take a look it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in amy
our first question
how long does it take for a proof of
principle to be run
so the first thing we'll do is work with
you to decide on exactly what we want to
test both what fits you best and what we
can run in
one run and after we've decided that and
fully locked down we will the aim is to
have
samples shipping back out to you within
two weeks of receiving your reagents on
site for a standard run
if it's a larger run and particularly if
it's a bead run this may be a bit longer
but we'll let you know beforehand if it
will be any longer
wonderful thank you and now how many
excipients do you have
so we do have a range of excipients we
have uh eight standard ones if we need
them typically we would start off with
up to four depending on the type of
assay we're lyophilizing and initially
we test them wet and
we try one or two in
the first three first few proof of
principle runs
thank you so much
our one audience member says i am iso
one three four eight five regulated can
you manufacture our products
yes we can so we are currently iso 9000
9001 regulated in cardiff uh
we are in the process of getting 13485
but we don't have it yet
and we do manufacture many 13485
products
thank you so much
now how much does a proof of principal
run cost
so the
uh ethos of the custom team is not to
make any money of the proof of principal
runs we will we look to cover our costs
so our proof of principal runs start
from as little as 1500 and
they go up depending on what the
the complexity of the pop and the number
of samples needed
thank you and i want to thank our
audience members for these great
questions
our next question is do we have to do
any validation on ourselves as part of
the proof of principle
so for the proof of principles there
would be no validation that we would
need to do however after
the aim of the proof of principles is to
get a product into manufacture and as
part of the manufacturing process what
we need to do is scale up so we need to
start
looking at things
um like how we dispense so in the proof
of principle runs we'll be dispensing 30
plates at a maximum properly
thank you so much
is it possible
to arrange a site visit to the cardiff
site
yeah um normally um we say yes at the
moment we're doing a lot more virtual
tours so we can give you a virtual tour
of our site and we can do virtual audits
and we can still welcome visitors if we
need to um
but normally yes it's we're very open to
visits
wonderful thank you we have time for one
more question what is the lead time amy
to secure a
gmp run
so it does depend on the complexity of
the project so
and once we've started
once we've done all the proof of
principles and we have a lockdown
formulation we will then start the
transfer runs now
this can take
anything from
six weeks to a couple of months or
longer depending on the complexity of
your project
and the
urgency of which everything is needed
and
we'll take it through to the core team
so
once we've done the development we then
report our findings to the head of r d
head of manufacturer head of tech
support and between us and working with
yourselves the customer we will develop
a
action plan as to checking out all the
risks that we need to look at before we
can put this into manufacture
once we've done the design transfer plan
and we've
validated everything that we've agreed
on
we will then need to set it up in our
system so it
and so it is manufactured as a full-on
product
so it can be
anything from a couple of months to a
couple
to longer depending on
complexity
and amy this same audience member wants
to know is it possible to get a copy of
this slide wheel of services provided
um we could we have a copy of the
information so in our booth the
accelerating diagnostic development with
custom design services there is a
collection of web links one of those for
the custom services for genomics
is links to a web page which has all the
information that was in that slide
wonderful amy thank you for your
presentation today and for your
important research
would you like to offer any closing
remarks to our audience before we go
just thank you for listening and if you
have any further questions and please
join me in the booth
amy thank you again amy webster and i
want to thank our audience members for
their participation any questions that
were submitted and not answered today by
our speaker will be addressed via email
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for up to 12 months so
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic and don't miss out on the
other presentations on our agenda visit
the agenda tab at the auditorium for a
full listing thank you again for your
participation until next time take care
stay healthy and stay safe bye